- I'm such a fan!
- Hi, everyone.
Thank you.
- I am such a fan!
Like, seriously, such
a fan, you know this.
- By the way, when you get here,
she wrote me a handwritten note.
(audience sighing)
I mean, you're so sweet. When
did you have time to do that?
- Oh, I write handwritten letters
for every guest on my show.
(audience sighing) Yeah, yeah.
- That is the sweetest.
- Well, it's important, I know what it is
to make the rounds.
- Such a fan.
- Hey, and I'm also a superfan
and you know this because.
- You came to our set.
- I did.
Do you remember that?
I was--
- She came to our set
in like 2011 or '12.
- I was on tour.
I don't remember that.
I have no memory, we were
talking about that earlier.
- I do know that in 2012, we
were Tater Tots, for sure.
- It was awesome though,
that show is so great.
- That was a long time ago now.
- Yeah, I know and now it's
2020 and we're all grandpas.
- And I'm sitting on
the stage with legends.
- Have you ever met them before?
- I'm moving a little closer.
(audience applause)
- No, I've never met.
- Sorry, I keep creeping
over here a little bit.
- It's a gravitational pull.
- I had never met them but,
I mean, you know, any boy
at that time completely had
a crush on you guys, so.
- Yes.
- Oh gosh, wow.
- They were like the biggest thing.
- And all the girls wanted to be you.
- Since like peanut butter.
You guys were huge.
- Where's my cane?
(laughing)
- Did you guys ever get
into the vampire stuff?
You all remember the vampire--
I'm obsessed.
- I don't watch TV.
I don't watch TV.
- You don't?
- Does "Twilight" count?
Does "Twilight" count?
- "Twilight" counts.
Yeah, that's all vampires, yeah.
- My wife was actually in "Twilight".
- Yeah, Nikki Reed, your wife.
Yeah, was in "Twilight".
- My daughter Jamison's
"Twilight" obsessed,
so there you go.
- Yes, I read all the books
before even the first movie came out.
I love anything, kind of, fantasy.
I think because sometimes
life can be so not good.
- Chaotic and insane?
- That you're like, "I want escapism",
and you do it so well.
- Well, thank you.
- Yes, I loved visiting
y'all's set, it was so cool.
- Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- And Paul Wesley actually just here, yes.
- So the guy that played my brother
on this very long running
TV show, we love each other.
We have wanted to kill
each other about 800 times.
- That means brothers.
- But that means brothers and we have now,
not only were we on a television show
for eight years together
but now we've started a company together.
- Wow.
- And it's really special.
The Salvatore boys, the Salvatore
brothers, have a bourbon
and it's gonna be a lot of fun.
- So wait, what's the name?
Are you announcing the name yet?
- Not yet.
- Not yet, okay, so it should,
I mean, Salvatore Brothers.
is pretty great too, but.
- Trademarking, copyrighting,
everything is done.
- You're now, with "V Wars",
you're the executive producer,
director, and you're
starring in "V Wars", right?
- Yes.
- Yes, yes, yes.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you.
- Explain to people,
because it kinda looks,
it's about, kind of,
vampires but not really,
it's, like, kinda different.
It's like disease almost
takes over, right?
- It's the only vampire
show you've ever seen
that's actually ever been,
that is not supernatural.
It's science-based.
This is about a disease, a
pathogen that's found, a virus
that's found because of melting glaciers.
Things are starting to be
exposed that are very harmful
to humanity and livestock
and wildlife and stuff.
So, these are things that
it's not even possible,
it's probable, that
there are gonna be things
that come out and get into society.
- And can I say something
because everybody gets in
this battle about if humans
caused it or whatever.
Who cares what caused it?
It's happening.
- It's happening.
- But let's figure it out.
- Yeah and all that's amazing,
but do you ever get mistaken for Rob Lowe?
(laughing)
- I just had him on, as well.
- [Chynna] Well, you're both, you know,
not hard on the eyes.
- Rob is a--
- You guys could be brother twins.
- Totally.
- Rob is awesome.
He was so sweet, he walked up to my wife.
He walked up to Nikki Reed at a,
I think it was a Golden
Globes party or something,
and he walked up to her
and she had never met him.
He walked up to her
and he grabbed her face
and he just said, "This is
what you're gonna be looking
"at in 15 years."
(audience laughing)
- No, are you serious?
- Yeah, and he was so sweet
and respectful about it,
and she just--
- This is what you're gonna
be looking at in 15 years.
- That's a trip.
- But any woman that is
that close to Rob Lowe,
is sort of like, "Whoa."
(audience laughing)
And it was very sweet.
He's a really sweet man, he's awesome.
- But I think that that's really
cool that people might seem
that "V Wars" is
far-fetched, but I do love
that it's based in science
and a lot of things actually
happening in society.
- Well, it also attacks a lot
of the big tentpole things
that we're dealing with
right now in society.
We want to have this feel of genre enough,
like a "Walking Dead"
but the social relevance
of like, "A Handmaid's Tale".
I mean, these are shows that
really have affected people.
- Wow, I love you.
- Yeah, I mean happiness,
at the end of the day--
Well, I love you back, man.
- You are so great.
You're a high-fiver.
I love, I'm a hugger.
- Yes.